during the pangaea's period or sideshow
Pangaea
it's an era no yeah it's well when they
think that all of the continents were
connected together oh yeah we are one we
were one flat earth flat table flat no
no not a giant chunk and then the rest
was water and then it spread out which
is fucking weird is happening how did
that in like also is that happening on
our insides unlike us it's obviously on
a cellular level everything's just
splitting and being torn the fuck apart
there it is
here's the the modern Pangaea map was is
modern the modern country separations
and all that because oh this is what it
looked like I thought this is America
what is that I thought there was some
knuckleheads that thought that is that
really all the continents together
whoa it shows you how much goddamn water
there is water that's a mind fuck yeah
cuz you really like to think that we're
all dirt and not as much water it's so
much water it's all water it's like a
little speck in a huge ass ocean that's
what's really crazy those
ground-dwelling motherfuckers have
figured out how to suck all the fish out
of that water just to be able to get
those suckers out sometimes with your
bare hands and then they're like yo we
need something we need a smaller
situation I think until they came up
with the nets and stuff like that I
don't think they were real effective I
think they just got what they got and
they ate that but the populations were
fine yeah but in the last whatever 150
years they've been using Nets they just
jacked that whole ocean what do you
think happened to the dude who figured
out like the hook he probably got all
the pussy in town but due to like hook
the fish he was getting all those
fishies he was getting the ones that
were way deep what the kind of pussy
that you would get back when you
invented you don't want it in your
modern mind you don't but then you're
like yo this is fresh fresh it only
smells like musty how'd you become
something's happening to you
[Music]
level four
yeah I can to my group let's guess how
long ago do you think they invented the
fishhook do they even know I'm gonna say
it's a really old invention rolled
arrowhead time yeah exactly like native
native before pre those bitches would
just break if you think about a big fish
hooking like a little thin would they
make it that bone probably must be bone
you think don't want to be too heavy so
just thinking what would also break yeah
I wouldn't be able to get well yeah it
must have been bone I bet it was bone
yeah but bones get brittle especially
after like you know they're off the body
and they start to mm-hmm
calcify and all that but how old do you
think it is it's got to be really old
juniper what it says juniper wood was
the first one time twenty-three thousand
years ago boy Christ
there's Norwegians yeah they were made
from sea snail shells a bunch of
information all put together in this in
Okinawa Island dated between 20 2003 80
and 20 2007 70 and that crazy they get
it that close they're basically in an
inner you know give or take 80 90 years
100 years I it's like is it carbon
dating I mean that's the only thing I
remember from high school how do you
even how do you date it back do they
find is it like a forensic thing where
they grab a fly and they're like yeah
this was six years ago because of the
juices on the wings
I think it's B there's like a bunch of
factors like one of them is the dirt
that's around where they fry it like if
they find it on the ground then it's
covered with dirt over hundreds and
hundreds of years they could take some
of that dirt and test it yeah it's in it
they they're trying to test
I think whoa that's crazy I want those
as earrings is that a fish hook yeah
that click do that's how the showers yo
those are fresh those are really nice I
would rock those would you yeah a story
oldest fishhook found in Okinawa Wow
twenty-three thousand years ago that's
crazy
and so they're saying that the oldest
fish hook is linked to the Norwegians I
would say Japanese this says Okinawa
yeah
Norwegian thing was saying that and up
until the 1950 is their word they were
still using wood and Oh
like a added fact yeah japanese makes
sense when if they all figured it out
the same time different spots in the
world you know whether it's one of those
things like you know I think there's
this some weird thing who's that is that
Rupert Sheldrake it's the morphic
resonance theory he's got this weird
theory that I think the idea is that if
some rat learns a maze on the East Coast
rats on the West Coast will learn that
maze quicker what Wow like a like a they
don't know the collective consciousness
amongst the rats as weird as it sounds
there might be some sort of strange
connection that all rats share and not
just all rats but all living beings his
argument was that if this is
demonstratable with a rat in a maze that
if they did something like with human
beings if they could figure out a way to
to prove this that's likely what's
happening is that like he brought up a
bunch of different factors like
inventions that are simultaneously
taking place like all over the world
like what and strange you should
attribute some of that's education right
like yeah definitely education what's
going on like that the the trends that
are happening in education but like but
they also think there might be something
else going on underneath the surface
like on a different realm like if you
learn if we're all a species and you're
on one side of the world you learn
something the people on the other side
of the world have like greater access to
it in some weird way that's really
bizarre